this is conmigo an AI powered guide
designed to help all students learn
kanmigo is not just for students
teachers can use conmigo too by toggling
from student mode to teacher mode
once in teacher mode conmigo transforms
into the teaching assistant you've
always wanted
kanmigo has many exciting features that
supports teachers and this video will
showcase ways teachers can use conmigo
to get ideas for engaging lesson plans
activities and teaching strategies
explore how conmigo's fun and eccentric
personality can help teachers create
unique and engaging learning experiences
for their students
[Music]
conmigo I am going to be teaching a new
standard this week could you please
refresh my knowledge
[Music]
it's actually all coming back to me
could you help me create a lesson plan
[Music]
thank you
thank you so much do you have any Khan
Academy videos that I can share with my
students
you even included the links wow that is
so helpful thank you Khan Nico
[Music]
could you come up with a lesson hook
that I can use with my students
[Music]
that's a good idea but could you help me
come up with a funny lesson hook for
this
that is funny and it definitely should
get their attention thank you
I'd like to check my students
understanding at the end of class do you
have an exit ticket that I could use for
this
[Music]
oops I almost forgot do you have a quiz
that I can assign to my students
[Music]
before I forget do you have a funny poem
that I can share with my students to get
them excited about this topic
foreign
how about a poem about not having
homework with this topic
they'll love that
[Music]
this is awesome you just saved me so
much time conmigo thank you so much have
a great night
where would I be without you
[Music]
are the best teaching assistant ever
we hope you love kaimiko as much as we
do thanks for watching
[Music]